CHRIS DIBONA: Hi everyone.
My name's Chris DiBona.
I normally look after open
sourcey stuff for the company.
But I also help out on the
NASA relationship side.
And one of the things that we
were talking about with the
folks at Ames and at NASA was
having more sort of the right
exchange of people back and
forth between Ames and between
here in Mountain View
and Google.
And so this is sort of the
beginning of that.
What we want to do is basically
have a monthly, or
even more than that, series of
speakers coming over to speak
about interesting topics from
our friends at NASA about all
of the things they
work on there.
And so this is the first taste
of that with Mike Micire.
MIKE MICIRE: Close enough.
CHRIS DIBONA: We were
working on the
pronunciation of his last name.
Apparently, anything with M and
an E at the end is enough.
So the added distance in so
many words is just very
appealing to me.
Yeah, so he's going to talk
about the Android thing.
One thing I want to point out.
If you want to help with this
particular project, we have a
form that you can fill out.
I'd say email me, but give
me about a week or so.
I'm still recovering
from Perth.
But it's sort of a free time
thing where you can help out
with the SPHERES project.
As well as with other NASA
projects I think
that would cover too.
MIKE MICIRE: So first
of all, thank you.
First of all, the turnout,
this is awesome.
I'm really excited to not only
show you a lot of the stuff
that we've been working on, but
there are lots of smiling
faces I see in the crowd that
actually helped us do the
things that I'm going
to present here.
And so I'm really kind of stoked
to tell you about the
cool experiments and stuff that
we've been doing on the
International Space Station.
So I have basically two
versions of this talk.
One version is very managery
and talks about level one
milestones and reach goals and
Gantt charts and other stuff.
And I decided, because I kind
of feel like I'm amongst my
people here as far as the good
geekery goes, that this would
be kind of just a geek-to-geek
conversation.
And so rather than dive into a
lot of the kind of managerial
details, I wanted to just talk
about the stuff, frankly, that
makes me get up and want to
go to work every morning.
We've been privileged to do a
lot of really cool stuff.
And so I'm just going to kind
of tell you the story that
brings us to current date
in terms of the
stuff we've been doing.
I'll also add, this actually
works better if it's
interactive.
And so if I hit a slide, and
you have a question or
something like that, just throw
up a hand and we can
dive into it.
There's a lot of really, really
cool details that we
can get into.
And so I'll skim the surface,
and you guys let me figure out
when I need to dive.
OK?
So right after we did one of our
first tests, actually some
folks here in your production
group frankly did a better job
of describing this than most.
And so what I'm going to do is
we will start with a video.
MALE SPEAKER: Five.
All three engines
up and burning.
Two, one, zero.
And liftoff.
The final liftoff of Atlantis.
On the shoulders of the space
shuttle, America will
continue the dream.
MALE SPEAKER: The space shuttle
spreads its wings.
DW WHEELER: What we're working
towards is a future in which
we can have robots that will
take over a lot of menial
tasks that astronauts do.
Our first goal for our project
is to have ground controllers
driving the SPHERE around
on the space station.
The SPHERE will take data and
pictures and sensor readings
and send that back
to the user.
MIKE MICIRE: She hooks it to the
front, and at that point,
the phone will be able
to tell the SPHERE
where it needs to go.
The processor, the camera, and
all of the sensors that are in
the Nexus S become the brains
of the robot and tell the
SPHERE where it wants to fly.
The wi-fi on the phone connects
to the station wi-fi.
That gets linked down
to the ground.
And then hopefully we're going
to be able to control it from
the ground.
DW WHEELER: We chose the Nexus
S because the phone is very
easy to take apart.
Android is easy to program.
We're familiar with it.
And we needed to make a lot of
customizations that are easier
to make with Android.
MIKE MICIRE: Google was
also working on an
open source data logger.
And it met our use case
requirements.
CHARLES CHEN: You can download
this application for your
Android device.
And that's the exact
same application as
what NASA is using.
DW WHEELER: The more time that
the astronauts can spend doing
science, the more value we're
getting out of that
investment.
MIKE MICIRE: Our goal is to
provide enough value to crew
and enough value to operations
that they'll be able to keep
it up there for a long time.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE],
Houston.
MALE SPEAKER: Roger [INAUDIBLE],
Atlantis.
MALE SPEAKER: Houston
now controlling
the flight of Atlantis.
MIKE MICIRE: OK, so hopefully
that sets the stage.
Now, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to back up in time
and kind of set up how we got
to where we are today.
So geek test.
Who knows what this is?
MALE SPEAKER: It's
a training droid.
MIKE MICIRE: Exactly.
So it turns out if you back up
to, like, '98, '99-ish, there
was a couple different
groups that were--
strangely enough, all of them
kind of used this as
inspiration.
And it's the idea that if you're
in a micro gravity
environment, can you have
something that would be able
to float around?
And of course, the fact that it
made little thruster sounds
and stuff like that made it a
perfect metaphor, because
everybody effectively
knows what this is.
So if you step back,
this is PSA.
And this was actually developed
out of Ames.
And the whole idea with
this one is it was--
PSA stands for Personal
Satellite Assistant.
And it truly is.
If you remember from the Flubber
movie with Robin
Williams, the idea that it's his
little floating assistant
that will go around and do
things for him and bring him
stuff or be able to provide
instructions
or things for him.
And so that was one of the many,
many goals that this
project had.
Unfortunately, that program
was canceled.
At around the same time, this is
AirCam, which was a project
out of JSC.
And so this actually flew--
I think was one of the
STS-73, I think.
Where they actually had-- this
is about the size of a
basketball.
And it was able to fly around
in the back of shuttle.
Basically what they did was they
took the safer pack that
you see lot of the famous shots
of the astronauts doing
space walks in.
And they took the human part
out, compacted it down.
And when it flew, it essentially
looks like this.
And so they were able to very
successfully fly that around
and provide that as a
demonstration of how you might
have a free flyer working
in space.
Now, this is EVA.
So this is outside as opposed
to PSA, which was for inside
of station.
Now, at almost exactly the same
time, MIT had a-- and it
was like an undergraduate
capstone class where they were
trying to figure out, OK.
Can you use these small
satellites for doing testing?
They basically wanted to
create a test bed.
Because it turns out if you're
writing an algorithm for a
satellite or something and you
put it in space and it messes
up and manages to de-orbit
itself, that's both
frustrating and expensive.
But if we can do some of those
tests inside of station where
you have an astronaut there that
can grab it if it starts
flying off and doing the wrong
thing and be able to reset and
kind of iterate, that
there would be a
lot of value in that.
This is a bit of a
Cinderella story.
Because it truly did go from
being a project that students
were working on to, fast forward
to 10 years, and this
is basically what we have now.
There are three of
these on station.
We have, I believe, four
of them on the ground.
And one of them lives
over at Ames.
And we have a whole lab where
we use this day in, day out
for a bunch of different
projects and a bunch of
different science that
we're trying to do.
Just briefly diving into some
of the semantics here.
So the way the SPHERES work,
basically, is there's a CO2
tank that plugs into
the bottom of it.
This is a CO2 tank exactly like
what you would use on
paintball guns.
In fact, whenever our CO2
bottles end up getting low,
we've had situations where
we didn't have resupply.
And we actually will go to
Sports Authority and them
refill our-- and of course, they
say, is this for a paint
gun And we're like, no,
it's for a satellite.
And they're like, oh, OK.
So basically, the CO2 tank, it's
liquid CO2 that's passed
through a regulator.
The regulator then puts it
through tubing, basically,
inside that goes out to
these little yellow
thrusters that you see.
And there's a little solenoid
on each of those thrusters.
And so what the computer inside
is able to do is it
will just activate each
of those solenoids.
And that's how it releases
the thrust.
There's also ultrasonic
receivers on the outside that
I'll talk about in a second.
Because it's one thing to be
able to move yourself through
the environment.
But to do that meaningfully,
you have to
know where you are.
So that ends up being one
of the difficult tasks.
If you pop the hood on it, it
turns out that it's basically
an aluminum frame in which we
pack an insane amount of
electronics and sensors
and other things into.
Basically, one of the things
here that's kind of
interesting is for these
it actually uses
alkaline battery packs.
And so part of our job as far as
maintaining these is we end
up resupplying double A
batteries, basically, for
these satellites.
So I mentioned--
and I'm not going to go too
much of the details here.
But basically, the way the
SPHERE figures out where it
is, is it's floating in the
middle of a six by six by six
foot volume.
OK?
The first thing the SPHERE
does-- it has these little IR
transmitters on it.
And so it sends out
an IR pulse.
And you can think of that
as starting clock.
So it starts clock.
And then there's five beacons.
And on 20 millisecond
intervals, they have
ultrasonic transmitters that
begin counting off.
So start the pulse and then one,
two, three, four, five.
Each of those will do a click.
Now, the SPHERE, I mentioned
before, has these little
ultrasonic receivers all the way
around the outside of it.
It turns out that if you
consider the first pulse to be
the speed of light, which is
really fast, the speed of
sound is relatively slow
compared to that.
If you do the timing from the
beacon to the satellite, you
can actually do some math--
basically do some
triangulation--
and figure out where it is.
That plus a Coleman filter
gets us within a couple
centimeters of where the actual
position of the SPHERE
is within the six by six
by six foot volume.
So it's great in the fact that
it has a really good and
accurate idea of where it is.
The kind of downside is that
in a given module, this is
basically the only place
where we can fly.
Because if it gets outside of
that right now, it just
doesn't have the sensing
capability to figure out where
it is, to know where it
needs to go next.
What's cool is when they're
working, this is
what it looks like.
Now, I will admit, this is sped
up by about eight times.
So although they are awesome,
is a bit like
watching grass grow.
The cool part, though, is that
the astronauts love these.
And actually we never
have any problem.
Once we can get crew time,
they're usually very excited
to play with these.
And you can see, I
actually love--
Don Pettit's little toes
are just wiggling.
And if this doesn't get you a
little geek heart going, you
may want to go ahead
and leave now.
Because at least for me, this
is as very, very cool and by
the way, if you haven't, look up
"Saturday Morning Science"
with Don Pettit.
He's a pretty amazing geek, and
he will change, frankly,
the way you look at the world.
So let's then step into human
exploration and telerobotics.
And I'm not going to
go through these
in any great detail.
But just say that right now, we
live in a world where, at
least when I leave in the
morning, I reach down and kick
the little on button
on my Roomba.
And by the time I get home,
my house is vacuumed.
Google is doing amazing work
with the autonomous driving
cars and other things.
We live in a world today where
we're beginning to expect
robots to help improve our lives
and the things that we
have to do.
Our motivations are exactly the
same, but in the context
of the ISS and space travel.
So right now, for the crew that
we have on station, crew
time is not only extremely
valuable, but there's so much
upkeep and other maintenance
type things that they have to
do that sometimes the science
has to take the backseat.
So anything that we can do that
helps them get rid of
some of those menial tasks, or
helps ground controllers not
have to directly involve crew,
or improves the communication
between ground and crew is all
just huge value that we're
bringing to the resource of ISS
and any future exploration
that we do.
In this picture, one important
thing to see here is that we
have the SPHERES.
And we're using those as kind of
our platform, our test bed.
And there's really two ways
that we're feeding this.
It's not only crew being able to
control a robot on station,
but it's also ground controllers
being able
to work with this.
And these end up being two
dramatically different
situations.
Because when you're
on the ground, you
have huge time delays.
So it's not just going to be
like a radio controlled car
where you flip the switch and
suddenly you're piloting it
around on station.
There's a lot of really smart
software that has to go into
those SPHERES to make
that workable.
The other thing is if any of you
ever want to come over and
try to fly a sphere,
even in 2D--
we have a granite table where
you can fly it around.
The fact that, like with a radio
controlled car, if you
take your hand off the stick,
friction and other things will
eventually cause that little
car to come to a stop.
As someone who grew up with
radio controlled cars and
airplanes and other kinds of
stuff, it was humbling to try
to control a free flyer in a
frictionless environment, even
in two dimensions.
And so even if you wanted to,
you're not just going to have
somebody joy-sticking
this thing around.
So we said, OK.
The SPHERES is an amazing
platform.
We have lots of capability
here.
But one problem that we have
is the CPU that is in that
thing is already pretty
busy doing the math of
triangulation.
And it's about a decade old
processor at this point.
So it's an old TI-DSP running
at about 170 megahertz.
So amazing in its day, but by
today's standards, a little
difficult to work with.
So we were like, all right.
Well, we're good geeks.
We'll just upgrade it.
Upgrades are the way to go.
And so, believe it or not, we
didn't start this project by
saying, we are going to put
an Android phone or a
smartphone in space.
We laid the trade space
up on the white board.
And we said, OK.
Well, it's going to
need to be small.
It needs to be power-efficient.
It needs to have integrated
sensors, low power.
Of course, it would be cool if
it had like a Unix operating
system on it.
And we laid all this up
on the whiteboard.
And of course, we're
all sitting there
checking our emails.
I don't know where we're ever
going to find a device that
satisfies all of these
requirements.
This is impossible.
And what we realized very
quickly was that a smartphone
would be a very, very good way
to attack this problem, as
opposed to trying
to roll our own.
Now, that's humbling to say.
That even NASA cannot outrun the
technological advancements
that are happening in the mobile
phone market today.
That's pretty crazy.
Yeah, question.
His question was, how fast
are the control loops?
And I'm assuming you're talking
about for the actual
spheres themselves in terms
of their flight.
And the answer is,
you have multiple
threads that are running.
And so I don't know them off
the top of my head either.
So we can geek out after the--
we'll take that offline.
So we basically said,
all right.
Well, a smartphone would be a
really great way to do this.
And like I said, NASA is even
having a hard time outrunning
the advancements that are
happening in the mobile phone
market world.
And now the question was,
well, what could we do
to make this work?
And your trade off between
building your own versus
buying COTS is that if you buy
COTS, whereas on the one side,
you have a lot of engineering
the needs to happen, on the
COTS side you have a lot
of reverse engineering
that needs to happen.
And it's a little tricky when
you go to Samsung, for
instance, and say, hey, what
does your accelerometer do in
micro-gravity environments?
And they're going to smile and
go, well, you're NASA.
You tell us.
And so there was a bit
of a risk that we
had going into this.
And frankly, we had no idea of
the many risks that we were
accepting by going
down this route.
I throw this up.
I'm actually going to come
back to this slide.
But what I'm going to do is
talk through some of the
flight barriers, basically,
that we had.
When you put something on a
spacecraft in orbit, you have
lots of gatekeepers and flaming
hoops you have to jump
through to prove to NASA and
the safety guys that you're
not going to cause problems
on the spacecraft.
And so what I'm going to do,
I'm going to dive through
actually a subset of these and
show you some of the hacking.
It's not only hardware hacking
but software hacking, and in a
final case even social hacking
to kind of make the whole
thing happen.
Let me first begin by saying,
God bless the internet.
Because what happened was we had
talked with a couple other
groups that were using one
of the Nexus 1 phones.
And there were just some
barriers they were having to
climb through that we were like,
well, the Nexus S really
seems like the phone that we
probably want to fight with.
And iFixit somehow, about a day
or so prior to the release
of the Nexus S, managed
to do a tear down.
So we immediately
said, all right.
Well, let's start looking at
what this thing's got.
And the one thing that we were
told very early on was that we
had to hardware disable the
cellular phone functionality
of the phone.
For the same reason that when
you get on an airplane, you
have to either put it in
airplane mode or physically
turn it off.
It turns out the ISS has similar
rules, and it's pretty
much all the time.
It needs to be in an
airplane mode.
And we told them-- we said,
well, in the kernel, we can
completely disable the phone's
ability to talk to the radio.
We'll guarantee that
there's no way this
radio can be activated.
And unfortunately, the comeback
was, well, no.
Actually, it needs to be
a hardware disable.
You have to have a hardware
switch or some way of
physically making sure that
transmitter can never fire up.
And we were like, OK.
Well, I guess then one way of
doing that would be to pull
the-- basically your
TX front end.
This is the cellular phone
part of the phone.
And we were pretty sure that if
we could disable that chip
that we would be able
to pull that off.
So myself and one of my other
engineers actually camped out
at the Best Buy up
at [INAUDIBLE].
And I think there were 13 phones
that were delivered to
that Best Buy.
We got numbers 11 and 12.
Immediately took it back to the
lab, completely pulled it
apart, and laid up
on a heat bath.
Basically what this does is--
you can think of it
like a crazy hair
dryer blowing upward.
And the whole idea is what
you want to do is you
want to heat the board.
And then this is an air pen.
Basically, we knew that this
chip was a BGA, which means
it's soldered on the bottom.
And unfortunately, with it being
a BGA, you're not just
going to take an exacto knife
and cut the enable pen and
have it work.
So we said, all right,
we've got this.
We're going to own it.
And we failed epically.
I laid this up under the
microscope, and it looked like
a tiny little Civil
War battlefield.
There were capacitors
and resistors just
strewn all over this.
But I'm a big fan of fail
fast and fail often.
And so we were like,
all right.
We've got two phones.
Let's screw up a second one.
And the important subtlety to
this presentation is you can
see, actually, this is
now glowing red.
So we were like, well,
let's burn it up.
Worst thing we can do is
ruin another phone.
And so the cool part was we
actually managed to figure out
a way to lift that chip.
And we got pretty good at it,
to the point where you could
pull it, you could clean it
up under the microscope.
And the phone is none
the wiser, luckily.
It just thinks it's sitting out
in the middle of Nevada
somewhere with no
signal strength.
And it just kind of quietly
sits there not getting
cellphone access.
The next thing we needed to
figure out is, we were told
lithium ion batteries were very,
very hard to certify to
get on station.
It has to do with the way that
lithium can sometimes go super
critical, depending on
what you do with it.
But we were told, if you go
alkaline batteries-- if you go
double A batteries,
that works.
There's so many things on the
station that run off of double
A batteries.
You hear the metric of how
many dollars per pound it
costs to lift something
into space.
I don't ever want to do the
math on how many double A
batteries we resupply to
the space station.
So it was like OK, so let's find
something that will hold
double A batteries.
Luckily, I think Adafruit
was where we got this
space-certified battery
holder.
We basically sourced
a battery holder.
We had already done some other
projects with this little guy,
which is a basically a DC to
DC switching regulator.
And the important part is it's
got this little adjustment
knob on the front of it.
And we figured, all right.
Well, we'll feed it with
double A batteries.
And then we'll let this little
switching regulator trick the
phone into thinking it's
got a lithium battery.
It's important to make sure that
you don't charge the DC
to DC, though.
So we threw just a simple
little diode in there.
We basically ruined the back of
another Nexus S phone and
figured out how to cut all of
this out so it would fit, and
then started doing
some testing.
And this is another just kind of
get it done moment where it
was like, well, we could
instrument this whole thing
where we were logging the
voltages and stuff like that.
So what we ended up doing was
just taking a phone, putting
it on time lapse, taking
pictures of two volt meters
until the phone went dead.
And then took all of those
pictures and hand entered them
into a spreadsheet.
Now, there's and important
subtlety here.
You'll see why it's important
in a second.
In this case, I'm actually
taping the phone to my laptop
because I didn't have anything
else to stand it up against.
And there was a moment where I
was like, well actually, I
just taped it to my laptop.
How am I going to push
the buttons?
And it turns out you can push
buttons through tape.
And so the whole thing
ended up working.
And the good news is we were
able to fake a phone into
basically running off of
double A batteries.
We can get about seven
hours out of it.
And the important part here.
Lithium ions cruise along and
then drop hard in the end.
And that's, frankly, why
everybody that does digital
electronics loves them.
Because it'll hold a reasonably
constant voltage
for a long time.
That's what an alkaline does.
And so the DC to DC ends
up being a great
little tool for us.
So the other thing that we
were told was, you've got
glass on the front
of this phone.
What happens if an astronaut
decides to fast pitch it, and
it goes into the corner of some
handrail or something,
and he breaks that glass?
And now you've got little
shards of glass.
We break glass here on earth,
and the glass falls to the
ground, and everybody goes,
ooh, don't stand near the
glass, because you might
get it in your feet.
In micro gravity, though, those
are little shards of
things that you may breathe.
That ends up being a much, much
more significant hazard.
And so we were told,
all right.
You need some way to
contain the glass.
Now luckily, I had already
accidentally figured out that
clear acrylic packing tape,
that you can touch the
capacitive touch screen
through that.
It kind of makes those $20
screen protectors at Best Buy
seem a little expensive,
doesn't it?
Now pretty much for all my
screen protectors, I just lay
packing tape over it, and
then take an exacto
knife around the edges.
And that's basically
what we did here.
It turns out that acrylic tape
is considered flammable by ISS
safety considerations.
So we actually ended up
using Teflon tape.
Because we had actually done it
all up in acrylic, and they
were like, no, no, no, no.
So of course, once you do
it, you have to test it.
And so we destroyed another
perfectly good Nexus S. But it
was for science.
And the good news here
was we were able to
basically contain the glass.
So both of the phones that
we actually flew are
covered in this tape.
And you can pretty obnoxiously
damage the screen, and of
course it keeps all
the glass intact.
And when you get it all put
together, this is what it
looks like on a SPHERE.
Basically, we Velcro it
right to the front.
As Han Solo said, it doesn't
look like much, but it's got
it where it counts.
And what this did was we
flew these on the last
shuttle that went up.
Now, there's an important
point here.
And that's that with all of this
amazing hardware hacking
and other fun stuff that we were
doing, we knew we were
going to come right
up to the wire.
And we had no software
written.
No software written.
Which would kind of be the
whole point, right?
Well, it turns out that,
luckily, we were really kind
of talking to actually
some folks that are
even in this room.
And you had a group here, the
cellbots, motley crew, as I'll
call them, that were already
working on some really, really
cool apps that were enabling
robotic-like interaction, but
using Android.
And so we ended up having this
wonderful collaboration in
figuring out how to take this
open source logger and allow
it to then run on station.
This gets back to the whole
question of going to a sensor
manufacturer and say, what
does your sensor do in
micro-gravity?
They are going to almost drop
the phone laughing at you.
And you also have to remember
that a lot of these sensors
are born out of other places.
So like the accelerometers
that we use.
A lot of that technology
actually came out of the
automotive industry where it was
for deploying airbags in
very high g environments.
So we had all kinds of questions
of, will these
sensors have the sensitivity
that we need to provide the
information that we want?
So this ended up being a kind of
a great addition and ended
up being one of the first tests
that we ended up doing
with the phone.
So let me circle back and talk
about some of the barriers.
So the first one-- procurement
and certificate of
conformance.
Real quick, a certificate of
conformance is basically--
let's say you're some
aero, astro company.
And I say, I need a flux
capacitor, and I needed it to
conform to the following
things.
And I give you a set
of requirements.
And then you run off, and you
build me a flux capacitor.
And then you come
back with it.
And you say, here's your
flux capacitor.
And here's a certificate of
conformance that says that
this conforms to the following
requirements that you gave me.
That's required for virtually
everything that flies.
Do you know how to get a
certificate of conformance for
a Nexus S that you bought
at Best Buy?
The answer is you show up
five minutes to closing.
You go to find the manager, and
you basically hand him a
piece of paper that says, Hi.
I'd like you to sign a piece
of paper that says that a
Nexus S is a Nexus S. And he
will look at you cross-eyed.
And the good news is you can
actually get him to sign it.
And we ended up doing this,
like, for instance, for the
battery holder.
I don't think that Adafruit had
ever worked with anybody
who needed a certificate of
conformance for a double a
battery holder before.
And so that was the one thing
that we found is that the
process that we use wasn't quite
tuned for the kind of
cool hackery and other things
that we were doing here.
I talked about disabling
the cellphone
part and the batteries.
The glass breakage
was a problem.
Mechanical drawings.
It turns out if you go to
Samsung and say, hi, I would
like the full CADs and
schematics for your phone.
Can I have that?
And so we basically ended up
having to kind of generate our
own mechanicals for
all of this.
The second-to-last one.
So here's a cool, fun fact.
All of the laptops that are up
on the International Space
Station are right now running
Windows XP Service Pack 3.
Do you know what happens when
you plug in a Nexus S into a
Service Pack 3.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE MICIRE: Luckily no.
Unfortunately, it starts
asking you for drivers.
Of course.
And unfortunately, to get a
driver certified for use on
one of these laptops
on station is a
multi-year Gantt chart.
Basically, we looked at
certifying a driver, and it
was longer than our
whole program.
And we were like, OK.
So what we basically did was we
ended up building our own
firmware for the Nexus S where
we were able to allow the
phone to kick into mass storage
mode before it was
ever plugged in.
I'm sure all of you know you
have to plug it in before it
asks you if you want to put
it into mass storage mode.
Because basically the UUID for
the mass storage device,
Windows XP Service
Pack 3 liked.
Whereas the USB multiplexer
that was on it would
immediately kick it into, I am
Windows, and I don't know what
you're plugging into me.
Please hit OK or tell
me where to go.
And so we were able to go
through and basically modify
the OS to our needs, which
was really important.
Because that would've
been a non starter.
And we didn't figure this
out until the 11th
hour, almost literally.
It was at the end, and we
plugged it into one of the
test laptops, and it's
like, driver disk.
And we all had a heart attacks
simultaneously.
And then also, like I said, we
had no time for software
development.
And this is where a lot of the
folks in this audience and
with the cellbots group were
able to help us out
and back fill that.
So they took-- we actually
had the phones built.
I love this picture, because I
think the packing instructions
were more complicated than
anything we did prior to that.
MALE SPEAKER: I have a question
about the phone issue
and the USB.
MIKE MICIRE: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Why did you need
to plug it in the USB at all
if you-- can you
use the wi-fi?
MIKE MICIRE: So actually, very
early on, we were not cleared
for using wi-fi.
The network on ISS,
of course, can't
call out to the internet.
And so we had debated the idea
of, well, could we load the
APK through and 80B
over wi-fi.
And basically, what it came down
to is the shortest path
was for us to--
we uplink the APK to station.
They put the phone into
mass storage mode.
We copy the APK over to the
SD card on the phone.
And then we have basically an
app on there that'll do a
local APK install.
And that was the shortest path
to get us through to flight.
So we're actually now going back
and-- frankly, now that
we know a lot more about
Android than we did
originally, we're
going back and
revisiting that whole process.
And it would be very cool
to be able to just
load it over the wi-fi.
So it went up on 135, which
was really cool.
For myself, not only being able
to know that my team had
cool little stuff sitting in the
back of that pickup truck.
But we also got to go down there
with a lot of the folks
that helped us to build
this thing out.
Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Does the phone
connect to [INAUDIBLE] the
SPHERE, or no?
MIKE MICIRE: We'll get to
that in just a second.
So the question was, does the
phone connect to the SPHERE.
And it would be very
anti-climatic if it didn't.
So Atlantis passed
it into ISS.
And actually, I was just
reminded that the anniversary
of this is pretty much
a year ago today.
This is the SPHERE with a phone
stuck to the front of it
flying around on ISS.
And this is what
it looks like.
This is, again, sped up for
your viewing pleasure.
But you can see that
the phone's kind of
stuck to the front.
And what this is doing is the
SPHERE is running through a
series of maneuvers that are
allowing us to log basically
what all the sensors
are seeing.
So we didn't know if the
accelerometer was going to
have enough sensitivity.
We didn't know if the gyro was
going to be able to detect the
change in movement and such.
And so this was kind
of our acid test.
You'll also notice--
I apologize for the
video quality.
Hopefully this will load.
There we go.
We were having a bit of a
problem with the SPHERE that
day with it resetting.
And it had to do with the IR
mechanism I was talking about
being jammed by the lights that
are on station there.
It turns out when a fluorescent
light begins
malfunctioning, it emits a
lot in the IR spectrum.
And so we basically to turn
the lights way down.
So what you're seeing
here is this is the
view out of the camera.
And this is me doing some
guerrilla image processing to
bring the light levels up.
And so the good news is that,
at least in terms of camera
performance, even in low light
conditions, that we're able to
see artifacts and figure
out what's going on
and where it's flying.
The gyro.
We smile because--
what we've got here.
So this is the test on
the ground, and this
is the test on orbit.
And each of the little kind of
edges that you see here,
that's a thruster firing.
So you're actually seeing
the change there.
And the good news is, based on
what we see on the ground
where we can only really move
in a 2D plane, we do have
enough sensitivity in the
gyroscope to be a useful
sensor to us.
MALE SPEAKER: How well
did the compass work?
MIKE MICIRE: This is the
one that surprised us.
We did not expect the compass
to be useful.
We were like, I don't know.
What does the magnetic field
look like in orbit?
I'm sure it's there, but what
does north mean when you're
going 17,000 miles an hour in
an orbit that is like this.
North becomes very relative.
But to our surprise, this
actually is working a lot
better than we thought.
And we're actually investigating
using this.
Because there are ways, a
course, for us to know where
ISS is in orbit.
And so if you can
come up with--
granted, north moves for you.
But then they tell you, even in
the base case, may tell you
interesting information like,
where is the floor?
Sometimes for a robot,
that's an important
question to begin with.
I don't need to know my
absolute pointing.
But if you can just tell me
where the floor and the
ceiling is, that allows me to
bootstrap some of the higher
level algorithms that
I might use to
begin localizing myself.
So this is one that frankly, we
have very important people
working on this right now.
MALE SPEAKER: Are there other
scientific instruments with
magnetometers doing any sort
of magnetic science?
MIKE MICIRE: Yes.
And so we are actually working
with actually a couple
different groups.
And what's kind of fascinating
too is we have talked with
other research groups within
NASA that were
surprised about this too.
And now we're talking about
possibly rolling smartphones
into other products that are
not even robotics related.
They're like, wait, you can
get pointing out of that?
That's very cool.
The gravity sensor, it turns
out, couldn't detect gravity.
Which is good.
That means you know we
didn't fake this in a
sound stage in LA.
And so that was kind of fun.
The bad news is, unfortunately,
the
accelerometer just doesn't
have enough sensitivity.
It ends up being
a lot of noise.
And we're actually looking with
a couple different folks
at seeing if we can pull
signal out of this.
Now, that's kind of
the bad news.
The good news is the SPHERES
actually have really, really,
really good accelerometers
already inside of them.
So this would have been kind
of a freebie if we could've
used the phone's
accelerometer.
But sadly, at least it looks
like right now, that that
won't be a sensor
we'll be using.
So we then said, OK.
Well, that gives us a baseline
as far as what the sensors can
and can't do.
So we said, let's look at what
the network's going to be able
to do to us.
This is a very, very simplified
drawing of ISS down
to Building-- this is Building
30, which is the mission
control center in Houston.
And we have a workstation
that's down there
that we can sit at.
And the question was, how do you
get through all of these
pipes and up to the top?
And so what we first did was,
because the code that we were
running was written in Java,
we were able to take and
basically port it over to a
normal Linux Java install.
And we remote controlled a
PC and emulated a phone.
And made sure that we could talk
from station all the way
down to the workstation
that we had there.
This is actually
us sitting in--
its basically an engineering
back room in mission control.
And those images, believe it
or not, even though it's a
video on the ground, those
images are actually coming
from the space station.
And I apologize for
the shaky video.
It turns out it's really hard to
record things and take them
out of mission control.
And so the way that we capture
most of this is me standing
there with my smartphone trying
to be as still as
possible videotaping
the screen.
And this was able to show-- we
had echo tests and other
things that we were running.
And that gave us a really good
benchmark of what was working
and not working.
The other important part here
is this isn't just us.
There's actually a whole team
that is out at Johnson Space
Center that helps us.
And so what was really fun is
that after we got out of the
kind of geekery and engineering
that we were
doing, we found out that there's
this whole other kind
of extended family that we have
out there that's helping
us get a lot of this
work done.
The thing that was really cool
after this experiment was we
got an opportunity to walk out
on the floor of mission
control and talk to the flight
director, who immediately was
like, what you guys are
doing is amazing work.
I want Google Video chat on a
robot as soon as you can.
And it was pretty validating.
Because frankly, up to this
point, we knew we were doing
good science.
But it's just nice when folks
that are doing the hard work,
that are there at the consoles
come up to you and
say, this is cool.
This is value.
Can you please continue doing
what you're doing?
And so to have the flight
director for that orbit say, I
want video chat.
I want to be able to chase
astronauts around.
And the big thing--
if you watch NASA TV a little
bit, and you see the way like
the cameras are set up.
And you'll see astronauts flying
around and doing stuff
or whatever.
That's great.
But what's really tough is when
that astronauts working
on your experiment.
And you need that kind of over
the shoulder view, right?
And what they'll do is you'll
spend the first 15 minutes of
any crew interaction setting
up the camera and
getting it in place.
And then the astronaut will go
down and immediately get in
front of the camera
and begin working.
And so especially for the ground
controllers, that's
huge to be able to nudge that
camera slightly and get a
view, or to go look at that
panel that's got the red light
and kind of figure out what's
happening there is just
bringing huge value
to these guys.
So then it was on.
It was like, OK, let's
use the phone.
And the big thing that we were
testing here that was
different before was we had
the actual smartphone.
And it was connecting over the
wireless access point.
The tricky part here was, like
with any wireless network, the
wireless access point isn't
in the module that
we're working in.
And we were told repeatedly,
it's like, oh, well, it's in
the next module.
You'll be fine.
The laptops use it
all the time.
And I kept having to remind the
engineers, it's like, OK,
your Lenovo T61 laptops have
this huge antenna that wraps
the screen.
Our antenna's about this big.
And we put a giant six pack
alkaline battery thing on the
back of this thing.
Depending on which way this
thing's turned, we're
attenuating that signal
pretty significantly.
The good news is we were
able to fire this up.
And that is an astronaut
cruising around with the phone
just unceremoniously
stuck to the wall.
And we ran this test and were
able to show that we're not
only able to get through all of
the tubes that we have to
get through, but that in terms
of wi-fi, actually, this was a
more difficult wi-fi connection
then what we expect
to see when we're in
the module that we
normally work in.
So we're good on wi-fi.
And that was the
important part.
Then, to your question, now that
we've tested comms and
we've tested sensors it would
be nice if we could actually
tell the SPHERE where to fly.
And so we ended up building
out this this--
it's basically a USB cable
that's going to a level
converter inside.
And that's connecting
to an expansion port
that's on the SPHERE.
There's an important distinction
here in that we
are not using this
as a USB port.
The Nexus S, as you may know,
has the ability to kick--
you can kick the USB
multiplexer into
a serial port mode.
And so because the SPHERE only
supports serial and not USB,
we actually use this as a serial
port and then use a
custom protocol to talk
to the SPHERE inside.
That went up on one of the
Soyuz resupply missions.
And this is what
it looks like.
So basically it just extends it
a little bit, and then with
the level converter kind of
tucks in between those two
plates there.
And this is an expansion port
that sits on the front of it
that crew can--
we are one of many experiments
that use this expansion port
for hooking things up.
The problem with being a
roboticist is that the
customer never wants
what you build.
And so what this does is it
allows customers to come to
the table and strap their
sensors to the front.
I show this not to explain it
but just to say, when you're
in orbit, and you have a lot
of time delay, and we have
this problem called
loss of signal.
And that's where for sometimes
30 and 45 minute windows, we
have no communication with the
ISS over the network that I
showed you.
It's just disconnected.
And so what we have to do in
software then is make sure
that we are compensating for
all of these different
situations that can arise.
So this is the user interface
that we're going to be using.
We're hoping to actually get
crew time in like late
November, early December.
And what we're able to do.
This is an interface that allows
us to set up plans that
the SPHERES will execute.
You say, Mark, why
is there a cat?
So imagine that every time you
see a cat, that's going to be
a view from the phone.
What we figured out-- and this
was a social hacking--
one of our colleagues that works
down at JPL has figured
out that if you can sneak cats
into your presentation to the
safety guys, it calms them.
And you don't get really,
really hard questions,
hopefully, afterwards.
So it's actually become a
challenge at this point.
We try to sneak cats into our
interfaces as much as possible.
So basically running very
quickly through this interface
that we developed.
First, we verify that we've
got a connection.
The neat part here is we're able
to come-- we basically
create these plans.
And what the plans do is they
tell you, I want you to orient
a certain way.
I want you to fly to
a certain position.
I want you to turn on
the flashlight.
I want you to take a picture
or start recording video.
And so we've come up with a
recipe or a plan that the
SPHERES is going to execute.
And we have these 3D views,
which allows us to preview
what we think the SPHERE
is going to do.
Once we've previewed that, then
this would be the image
that's actually coming
from the SPHERE.
And you see the progress
of where it is.
And again, the 3D views.
Whereas before it was kind of
giving you a simulation of
where the SPHERE was going
to be, this is
actually live telemetry.
So this is pulling the
positioning information back
out and then rolling it
into the display.
Then no good plan survives
first contact, and that's
especially true for robots.
About the time you think
you've got all the
combinations figured out, the
universe will throw you
something that you didn't think
about, and you've got to
go in and do some manual
adjustments.
And so what we've done
is provided a way
to do manual control.
Now this isn't like
rate control.
This is--
we call it nudging.
So if you tell it to go, and you
want to look at a panel,
or you want to position it in a
certain way, what you can do
is then you can nudge it
slightly and just kind of move
it in very small increments
left or right.
Left, right, up, and down are
all of its different degrees
of freedom.
And you have to remember that
you've got significant time
delay between you and
the spacecraft.
And so what this allows you to
do is go through and do some
nudging and reset things.
And like I said, all of that's
displayed up in the 3D image.
And that kind of brings
us to current.
So that's where we sit today.
Like I said, we're hoping that
in late November, early
December that we'll get
some crew time.
And what'll end up happening
is myself and some of my
engineers will be sitting
at consoles.
This will be running
on a laptop.
And we have a whole series
of plans where we will be
uploading these scripts
to the phone.
The phone then ends up
enumerating all of the plans
and figuring out how to turn
that into SPHERE speak.
And then there's a program that
runs on the SPHERE then
that starts executing
all of these things
that are thrown there.
So let me end by first saying
think you to the cellbot group
and all of the folks here at
Google that have helped us.
None of this that I've shown you
or in the future would be
happening without you.
And to lay a little bit of a
teaser, a kind of, we want you
kind of thing in here is
this is continuing.
And I don't expect this project
and similar projects
to go away any time soon.
We are definitely generating
interest within NASA.
Folks seem to be seeing value.
And the thing that we have now
is we're getting a lot of work
and, most importantly, a lot
of really interesting geeky
problems that we would
love to share.
So if you like kind of cracking
hard nuts and
figuring out how to make phones
and sensors do things
that they were never designed to
do in environments that are
very, very cool, either that's
my email address.
Or basically contact me,
and we'll find a way to
get you rolled in.
So thank you very much.
Were there any questions?
Go for it.
So the question was, how does
the SPHERE outside of station
figure out where it is.
That one was actually
rate controlled.
So that was a joystick that
was inside of shuttle, and
they were watching the video
on it and actually rate
controlling it from inside.
Now, because that was being
controlled from station, it's
a very low latency radio link.
And so it did not require the
kind of positioning that we
were looking at.
It does.
So the question was, does the
CO2 that we release end up
affecting the CO2 levels
on station?
And yes, it does.
It's not--
well, let's put it this way.
The engineers, when they first,
back in 2006, when they
flew this, basically they
figured out that the scrubbers
are more than capable of
handling the CO2 that this
ends up releasing.
But there are some flight rules
that we have that make
sure that we're not releasing
too much CO2 into that
environment.
Yeah.
So OK.
So the question was with respect
to the zero g flights
or the vomit comets.
Yes.
So actually, the photo that
you saw there with the MIT
students, that was actually
on NASA's vomit comet.
There are follow on projects
that have done the commercial
zero g flights.
Not only that has been done, we
also have both at MIT and
at our lab over at Ames, we have
a large, polished granite
table that allows us to float
the SPHERE in 2D.
You can kind of think of it as
an inverse air hockey table
where the puck is able to
levitate itself using CO2
being forced down and creates a
frictionless 2D environment
to do that.
We also software simulators that
are able to do a pretty
good job of demonstrating the
physics that we expect to see
in micro gravity.
We go through a pretty
exhaustive process of making
sure that the software is going
to do what we expect it
to do before we start
burning crew time.
Because that's the most
expensive part
of this whole equation.
What we don't want to do is have
crew set it up, and then
we haven't done our homework to
make sure that it's going
to do what we expected.
So the question is, how much
of the navigation is
handcrafted versus being
algorithmic?
Right now, at least with respect
to the control that
we're doing with the smartphone
itself, it's
basically way point
navigation.
Where we're able to tell it,
go to this coordinate,
turn to this pose.
And then it's actually figuring
out the thruster
mixing that it needs to do to
get from point A to point B.
So for any given orientation,
it's got to do the math of
figuring out what combination
of thrusters and timings it
needs to fire to get there.
There are ways of actually
having it go to more of a, I'm
following a path or a vector
through that space too.
There's been experiments
that frankly, we're
not using just yet.
But there have been
investigators that are
actually looking at, OK, if I
have this configuration of
obstacles, how with the thruster
configuration I have
can I optimize this path?
And autonomously make sure--
one of the big things for
free flyers is fuel.
How do you get from point A to
point B and make sure that
you're going to be able to
minimize your fuel usage so
you can get the point B. Because
unfortunately, again,
unlike on Earth, when you run
out of fuel, and you're
moving, you're going
to keep moving.
You don't eventually
come to a stop.
And so there's actually been
some really great research
that, frankly, we get to just
stand on the shoulders of
those smart people that have
figured out how to do those
kind of things.
Sure.
So the question is--
and I'm going to summarize
here-- is basically, we've
changed the center of mass
for this satellite.
And really the important
subtlety to that is the mass
that we've added to
it is outside of
the thruster volume.
And so right now, I don't know
if you noticed, but in the
video that I showed where it
was the low light video, if
you watch that video, it
actually lobs a little bit.
So when it takes off, you
actually see the phone angle
down a little bit.
And that's because for that
test, the SPHERE was almost
literally imagining--
in terms of its modeling,
it thought that it was a
perfectly spherical cow.
Like it really did think that
mass was equal on all sides.
The good news is that between
our group and MIT, we've been
able to tune the algorithm
that it's using
to adjust for that.
There's actually a project
that is separate from the
smartphone one that has a much
more massive sensor that it's
putting on the front of it.
And they've been doing
the hard math of,
OK, how do I model--
how do you not only model the
change in center of gravity,
but then the fact that that
center of gravity, in that
case, is probably almost pushing
itself outside of the
thruster envelope.
And that's hard math that I
won't even pretend that I know
how to go through myself.
So the question is, what do we
do on the phone versus the
controller?
So as roboticists we like to
look at things like motor
controllers and think of that
as like a black box.
I've got this high-level
algorithm, and it's just
providing a vector.
And then somewhere down below
in the layers below, it's
figuring out how much to
actually apply that H bridge
or that whatever.
The SPHERE, to our project,
effectively ends up being like
a motor controller.
We feel very fortunate that we
can tell it things like, go to
XYZ and turn to the following
pose, and it will figure out
the thruster firings and other
things to do for us.
So that's really kind of the
divide is that you can think
of the SPHERE as doing all of
the hard avionics side and the
smartphone side of it as working
the higher level, a
lot of the camera sensors,
the wi-fi [INAUDIBLE]
communication path.
And the really interesting part
for us-- and this changes
the way, frankly, a lot of
NASA's projects has gone, is
it allows the software
to be the science.
In that we can work on those
higher level algorithms and
know that there's this solid
base that's down below us
that's doing the avionics and
the flight part very reliably.
So the question is, what
kind of sensing
is done on the SPHERE?
And the SPHERE has
accelerometers and gyros on
each of its axes and the
ultrasonic positioning system
that I described.
So it knows where it is, and
it can sense motion.
And that's it.
There are no cameras.
At least in the base
configuration,
that's all it's got.
And so that was one of the big
values, frankly, that the
phone was bringing for us was
doing the camera and the wi-fi
and everything else that
we wanted to add on.
There's just a lot packaged
in that little box.
The question was, does the
SPHERE give information back
to the phone?
And yes.
We have a telemetry stream
that we monitor.
And that is what's communicating
to the phone.
In the plan that I described
there, that's how we know, OK,
it's reached this point in the
plan, and now we're moving on
to the next point.
So it's out of that telemetry
stream that we're able to
figure out that we've succeeded
in whatever that
sub-goal was.
So the question is, can we use
this, I'm assuming, as kind of
a litmus test or a test point
for future satellites?
And the short answer is, yes.
This is, frankly, a technology
demonstration for NASA and all
of the folks that are working in
these kind of environments.
And so our hope is to not only
be able to demonstrate but be
able to walk away with this
for, OK, here's your best
practices that you want
to try to tackle.
Here are the capabilities.
If you're going to, let's say,
choose a smartphone or some
type of COTS device, here's the
level of capabilities that
you're going to have to hit to
know what you're battling in
terms of what the sensors
are going to do
and stuff like that.
So it's a good data
point for us.
It'll be interesting to see how
many other projects end up
kind of globbing
onto this idea.
Like I said, I have other
projects literally calling me
probably weekly, just after
hearing about this, wanting to
know how we were able to use
these smartphones and what it
took to make them work.
So there's definitely
interest.
It's left to be seen, though,
whether we have other products
kind of getting on board.
Of course.
The question is, are we
going to upgrade?
And right now, frankly,
the Nexus S is a
great phone for us.
And we know it cold.
And that we're fully up under
the hood of that phone and
know it very, very well.
We have other projects that
are hopefully coming along
down the road here.
And of course, we're going to
go into that with the same
kind of open trade space that
we did before and say, OK.
We've had a couple
years go past.
Does it make sense now
to throw a panda
board up there, or--
and then lay up the leading
smartphones and try to see
who's got the best in class for
the kinds of things that
we need to do.
We're kind of mercenaries in
that we'll just lay up the
requirements.
And whatever can fill that
gap, we'll go with it.
So that's left to be seen
as to what phone we
actually end up using.
The question is, do
we use the screen?
And initially, when we first
started doing this, actually
the screen really wasn't even
on our list of requirements.
But as you probably suspect, the
ability for the astronaut
to be able to go up and interact
with the screen or to
start recording or to enable the
phone's functionality in
some way, or do something
simple like
configure an IP address.
MALE SPEAKER: Or dismiss
a force close error.
MIKE MICIRE: Or dismiss
Lovingly.
Which actually, we've done that
with our own code also.
MALE SPEAKER: Now that you have
front-facing cameras, you
can use it as a flashlight for
your low light [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE MICIRE: Yeah.
So the comment was, now that we
have front-facing cameras.
And actually, in this case, what
was kind of the downer
was because the big battery
pack is stuck to the back,
really, the high resolution
camera and the cool flashlight
are hidden behind there.
And before we flew, we actually
thought, you know
what would be really cool?
If we could periscope that.
Like two front reflecting
mirrors, and we can do the
double bank shot and get
that out the front.
And unfortunately, we just
didn't have time to do it.
But definitely, that is in our
requirements list for any
improvements that we do moving
forward is not only getting
the real flashlight.
Right now, we do the old G1
trick of, we just make the
screen really bright
and white.
And so we'd like for the future
projects to actually
have a proper flashlight that
allows us to illuminate.
Because as you can see,
we have instances--
and we didn't expect this.
And this would have hit
our requirements list.
But sometimes we have
to run in low light.
And that wasn't something that
we had really expected, at
least for these preliminary
experiments.
All right.
Any other questions?
Well, thank you very,
very much.
I really enjoyed this.